[Music]
is there credible
evidence to support the existence of an
afterlife a las vegas businessman says
he will spend a million dollars to find
out
mystery wire has the story las vegas
space entrepreneur robert bigelow known
for his funding of ufo research has
launched a new project
the bigelow institute for consciousness
studies or bix
bigelow will pay nearly a million
dollars for the top three essays
providing the best evidence that death
is not the end
the inventor and founder of bigelow
aerospace was motivated in part by a
series of personal losses in his family
and he wants to know is there an
afterlife the bigelow institute for
consciousness studies
is formed was formed to
try to conduct research
and facilitate research into
the possibility of the survival of human
consciousness beyond bodily death
and also to if
that is true
then to explore
what is the other side all about the top
essay will win
500 000 applications are being accepted
at the bix website
which also lists the rules our exclusive
on-camera interview with robert bigelow
on mysterywire.com george knapp
reporting